on parle beaucoup de surenchères
immobilière ces temps ci et ceux qui
cherchent une maison savent à quel point
les stressants de recevoir un coup de
fil du courtier qui leur demande
voulez-vous bonifié votre offre le plus
haut possible c'était une exception il
n'y a pas si longtemps c'est devenu
presque la norme dans certains marchés
certaines voix s'élèvent maintenant pour
dénoncer ce problème
ça faisait peau cinq minutes qu'on était
déjà dans la maison qu'on avait commencé
la visite qui est le ça sonnait des jeux
pour la visite suivante si on le sait
qu'on est principe du jeu la deuxième
visite qui lui arrive pas on se ramasse
rapidement avec à peu près trois
acheteurs potentiels
en même temps la maison
martin gauthier et jean françois
bertrand se sentent dépassés le marché
immobilier roulent trop vite il dit ne
pas savoir non plus les on est ce qu'ils
vont déposer une offre
les 30 heures de visite du même week-end
puis si oui à combien puis-je me makoun
qui qui est ce que je vois la perte
finalement pour cinquante mille neuf
cent mille où je vois la perdre contre
2000 dollars ils cherchent une maison
dans la couronne nord de montréal mais
pour eux entrés dans la course d'une
surenchère à l'aveuglé c'est
inconcevable il y avait certaines
raisons qu'on existe et qu'on trouvait
absolument exceptionnel
mais qui est justement là la logique
elle l'emporté sur le sol à cannes puis
on a décidé de prononcer sa masse
embarquée dans une course et puis
d'abord allongé plusieurs dizaines voire
centaines de milliers de dollars au
dessus des prix qui te demander en 2021
la surenchère moyenne sur une
unifamiliale a été de 10% de plus que le
prix demandé mais certains paient bien
plus comme ophélie piron et sébastien
breton dans mercier à montréal
il avait déjà raté deux propriétés parce
que leur offre n'était pas suffisante
donc on est deuxième on n'a pas la
maison et là on comprend que
on va devoir commencer la guerre est
plus haut et plus vite pour voir grandir
leurs familles dans ce duplex affiché à
5 198 milles dollars ils ont offert
presque 20 % de plus
finalement on est allé 108000 au dessus
un très angoissant de faire une oeuvre
sans savoir si on va dépenser beaucoup
trop d'argent aussi on va pas d'avoir
dans la grande région de montréal la
valeur médiane des maisons a bondi de
55% en deux ans samuel gladu et sa
conjointe ont été éjectés hors de la
ville dans nous riber vos passions
cachées avarie mais même à saint roch de
richelieu
il y a eu de la compétition ça courtière
lui a conseillé de surenchérir mettez
vos mimines de plus sinon vous leurrez
pas finalement après discussion notre
budget maximal c'était 265000 donc enfin
quinze mille de plus on a respecté notre
budget maximal j'ai mal dormi une miche
de com sur quoi je me base pour
investiguer 10000 dollars de plus donc
moi j'ai fait quelques recherches pour
savoir à quoi le montant qui avait été
émis contre mon offre à moins d'y aller
c'est dans les secrets des du tout seul
caché quelque part hors mais les
courtiers n'ont pas le choix les lois
leur interdisent de dévoiler aux
acheteurs le montant des offres
concurrentes aujourd'hui que le marché
qu'on a je pense quelque chose auquel on
devrait réfléchir loi le qui ça protège
puis pour tisser bénéfie l'aveuglément
des acheteurs peut être bénéfique pour
les courtiers et les vendeurs nous en
avons parlé à une vendeuse qui a requis
l'anonymat l affaire profits inespérés
sur les quatre offres que j'ai reçues
pour ma maison un des concurrents
sachant qu'ils avaient plusieurs offres
à dernière minute il rajouté 75 année-là
son prix mais la maison il leur ait eu
avec sa première offre c'était déjà la
plus haute il ya fait une surenchère a
lui même
payé 75 mille dollars de plus pour rien
c'est justement ce que craignent martin
et jean françois en ontario le
gouvernement à modifier la loi pour que
les offres peuvent être divulgués aux
autres acheteurs mais
seulement si les vendeurs le souhaitent
c'est totalement insuffisant selon les
auteurs d'une chronique immobilière du
financial post à toronto
on ne lit plus elle est selligent
choisir ça devrait être obligatoire
stephen morris a été président de la
chambre immobilière de toronto mortaza
haider est professeur de gestion
immobilière à l'université
métropolitaine de toronto
l'industrie devrait avoir comme priorité
d'être équitable et transparente à la
fois pour les acheteurs et les vendeurs
elle ne peut pas seulement protéger les
intérêts des vendeurs en dix ans les ach
affront bien ce qu'ils veulent les
gouvernements doivent établir un
équilibre
pourquoi perrier vous cent mille dollars
de plus que la deuxième meilleure offre
le législateur ne devrait pas laisser
aller les choses comme ça ce n'est pas
dans l'intérêt public
le printemps dernier
québec solidaire a fait pression sur le
gouvernement que gouvernement ajuste le
ministre des finances eric girard a
lancé une consultation sur les pratiques
des courtiers devrait-on changer la loi
et leur permettre de divulguer les
offres ça permettrait à tout le monde de
payé le bon prix et non pas un prix
complètement gonflé artificiellement
intimement chaque acheteur en riait
l'impression de donner un montant juste
mais les courtiers ont répondu non aux
ministres 1 parce que cela pourrait
priver les vendeurs du meilleur prix
possible et deux parce que cela pourrait
nuire aussi aux acheteurs
selon les courtiers ça pourrait
encourager la lutte entre concurrents et
exacerbé la surchauffe un argument
auquel ofili est sensible c'est dur à
savoir si au final avec une enchère
public on aurait payé moins on aurait
payé plus ou n'aurait pas eu
et qu'il ya un côté ou pour nous le
système actuel ne va pas ce que c'est ça
qui vous a permis de l'obtenir martine
et jean françois eux n'y croient pas les
gens pourraient dépasser leur budget
parce qu'ils sont comme aspiré dans la
frénésie de la contre offre mais si
c'est le cas ils feront connaissance de
cause merci cela en ce moment on le fait
à la bible les gens sont responsables
personne n'a dépassé selon leur budget
en australie les propriétés sont
couramment vendus aux enchères publiques
ça c'est la version exotique mais aussi
les enfants sur internet où l'on peut
enchérir de chez soi
là aussi le marché est en surchauffe les
acheteurs sont anxieux mais il enchérit
ce les yeux bien ouverts
avec plus de transparence certaines
maisons pourraient même se vendre encore
plus cher parce que les acheteurs
auraient davantage confiance dans le
système
le libre-marché fonctionnerait à son
plein potentiel avec des acheteurs bien
informée l'hybris agissent très en
fonction de l'offre et de la demande
l'industrie de l'immobilier repose sur
la confiance et la confiance s'acquiert
avec la transparence
ophélie et sébastien eux ont eu
confiance malgré tout
parce que leurs courtiers les a aidés à
bien analyser le marché on avait été
bien aiguillé puis on savait qu'on avait
un bon achat dans un prix qui est un bon
investissement
je trouve que c'est difficile de me
faire leur bonne foi parce qu'ils font
de l'argent avec le avec le que
j'investis plus je trouve ghost billet
le nous avons pu confirmer à samuel
qu'il ya eu deux offres pour sa maison
la sienne à 265 mille dollars supérieur
à une première offre à 250 mille dollars
le prix demandé si on était dans un
monde où les offres étaient publiques
est ce que vous auriez monté de 15 mille
de plus nous n'avons pas de
plans la connaissance de cause comme
ceux jadis 5000 de plus tri et vous
n'auriez peut être levé tout à fait ce
camp même pas négligeable c'est beaucoup
d'argent
là sur une rue donné quand une maison se
vend beaucoup trop cher à cause de la
surenchère à l'aveuglé ça fait monter
les prix des maisons voisines
quand on sait que unifamiliales sur deux
a été vendue en surenchère l'an dernier
au québec ça fait réfléchir pour martine
et jean françois même les vendeurs
devraient se sentir concernés vent d'une
maison cent mille ou cent cinquante
mille plus cher que ce qu'on a affiché
s'il faut se réengager à 150000 à 200000
plus cher que ce qu'on a question qu'est
ce qu'on devrait magazine et c'est pas
se partager pour personne
tant et aussi longtemps qu'on va pas
pouvoir agir de façon intelligente dans
le processus d'achat on continue à
regarder c'est sûr mais on
de façon peut-être plus passé
[Musique]
donc en ontario à partir d'avril 2023
les offres pourront être connus des
autres acheteurs ce qui permettra une
surenchère graduelle si les vendeurs le
veulent mais la question est là est ce
que les vendeurs voudront se priver
d'une surenchère exceptionnelle de
dernière minute d'un acheteur en panique
on verra du côté du québec le ministre
des finances n'a rien annoncé à ce sujet